joining me right now here on zoom on the
Rich Eisen show is a longtime friend of
mine loved this man loved working with
him and I'm not just saying that because
he's another handsome bald man with a
mustache and a beard he is a Super Bowl
champion quarterback in a a long time
friend as I mentioned Trent Dilfer how
are you Trent I'm do good I'm doing as
well as I can be doing rich I don't hurt
for the people struggling right now I
know me too me too juicy breeze gave
five million dollars in food relief and
he and uh Brittany gave five million
bucks in the state of Louisiana I mean
sounds like something he would do right
don't you think I mean so obviously
again knock on wood hopefully everybody
in your world is happy and healthy all
that said did I hear your voice on a
workout video with - oh yeah sweet was
that your blood you did yeah so uh yeah
- uh asked me after he had declared for
the draft if I'd handle his pre-draft
preparation okay unique circumstance
obviously weekend coming off the
multiple ankle injuries and they have
injury so we know is gonna be kind of a
slow grind as much of its been mentoring
as it is been coaching but now that he's
fully cleared medically we're getting
after it in terms of this preparation
for OTAs and we go all the way back to
lead 11 so I think there's a trust there
and I've never really been in the space
I purposely stayed out of this space the
spring drafts training space because so
many of the guys that I've mentored the
coaches around the country this is their
business I didn't want to ever steal
business from them but this is our
unique relationship with tua and because
of that I think he trusted me to guide
him through this process okay before we
can just dive in a little bit further
into that unique relationship I know
you've mentioned it to me on my show
before how you feel about him and how
you how long you've known him how does
he look to you right now he looks pretty
damn good to me in that video fantastic
and we've take another video since we
have a live throwing session today with
receivers when I get off this call what
his agent said is not far from the truth
if you if you
woke up from a coma for a year Aaron
didn't know anything that happened you
wouldn't think anything has changed he
looks as good if not a better than he
did pre injuries now to his credit he is
worse
I don't have the worst explained the
lonely work he's done to come back from
this I saw him at house aback did
something identify where he talked about
one of the keys to being a great
quarterback is how you attack rehab and
how you track the training room because
you're always beat up to a certain
degree and then many times you're coming
off catastrophic injury by Drew Brees
attacking the labrum tear greatest
example to reasonably become a
hall-of-famer after a map catastrophic
shoulder surgery because he attacks his
rehab as a total pro and to has done the
same thing with his injuries there were
six weeks where it was two and a half
hours a day twice a day lonely boring
rehab type stuff he couldn't throw for a
long time
soft toss was all he could do you could
imagine being a kid that loves throwing
a football and all you can do is sit on
a chair and throw
countless hours with me and Ken
Whisenhunt in my office going over the
football stuff completely changing how
he ate you know using nutrition as a way
of healing his body and now just this
week being able to come out and say okay
what am I and what he is is pretty
phenomenal well I mean and again just I
don't know if you chose that specific
snippet to make a point about his lower
body movement and his foot movement did
you because it sure looked like that was
a specific snippet that you chose yeah
he chose his first law I this is a weird
space rich and and you know this has
nothing to do with me that's why I
didn't release the video do it really
video he asked me to retweet it asked me
to share it obviously we knew I knew
being in the media for 10 years that it
was going to get picked up I all which
it should have been there's other stuff
that we'll release here in the next few
days that will show that he's fully back
and if he's not is plenty but he's even
better than he was before because he
got dipper been foundational he's built
on his Foundation different he's
stronger his core is much stronger
he's more functional with his movements
the biggest thing you tried to do is is
make him more rotary based instead of
spread out some of the injuries came
because he got spread out he got long I
got off balance is an easy way to say it
keeping him tired more compact or rotary
driven luke richardson who let his rehab
slash training was with the houston
texans forever won a Super Bowl at the
Broncos he's my strength coach here at
Lipscomb he guided him through those
first six weeks and I really made to me
changes with them so I say all that
because now when I asked him to do a
footwork drill and I try to do drills
that are that tray that translate into a
real football situation not just jumping
over stop and brooms all that you can
see the twitch and the power you can see
that in control this whole body you can
see him moving at center mass and not
just reaching for things you can see and
maintain this balance through different
platforms all this stuff is very
applicable to keeping him healthy as he
plays everything I tried to do and all
the things I've tried to communicate
with him is we're not trying to build
you for a fancy Pro day or where are you
going the draft I'm trying to build you
for a 15 year old Fame career
I think this kid is that special so
everything we're doing is I'm learning
from the great players I've studied
honestly I was not one of them but I'm
studying from the greatest of all time
their habits what they do their movement
strategies and trying to incorporate
those into to is training so it sure
looks like the drafts gonna go off as
scheduled Trent it looks like it's gonna
be the 23rd to the 25th I know that
there is some competition committee
conversations about whether that's right
or wrong because some teams are in their
facilities using the big board and being
able to gather other teams are in cities
and sheltered in place and they're not
allowed in their facilities so what what
does the next three weeks look like for
tua and turn
of getting on a horn with people or what
he needs to do to to potentially make
sure he's drafted as high as possible
best that you you can share you know
what I'm trying to my advice to him I I
can only share my advice to him has been
is to be yourself to is a unique kid in
a good way
he's got that really super cool
Polynesian vibe but he's got that
fierceness competitive like like
assassin quality to him to write to over
coach him in this process would be a
massive mistake to give him talking
points to try to make him somebody he's
not as he engages with these teams from
day one I told him in his family I only
want them to see the two of it I know
maybe a more refined version maybe one
that obviously is now moving in the
professional realm and not the
collegiate realm so there's refinement
to your to your personality your thought
process but he to her because when two
walks in the room the rooms
he's on a zoom call I'm pretty sure call
the teams that have talked to him
they're gonna say to see it jumps
through the screen we did a little
quarterback and Olympics yesterday just
me and him because it was kind of his
day off we just did like throwing drills
from our knees and targets and you know
set up things around the indoor and and
I had a beat twice and he came back in
the last seconds and beat me and you
know he he suddenly talks a little snack
he's got he's really good at talked a
little snack I'm devastated I'm laying
on the floor you know wine answering
because I thought I had to a beat he's
meeting me a little bit my point being
is that I just told him you be you and
then let the agent Chris cabin who's
fantastic what he does he can guide you
through the process how this works in a
new world but I think the more people
get to know do I know the media is gonna
love them I mean I already I already
trained I already do man and then trust
me Georgia knows the feeling about
thinking that too has been beat and then
he comes out at the last second it makes
throw so the the question I have though
is the physical part of it like are you
selling videos to teams or teams asked
for your particular insight to yeah well
we're working
in a bunch of video the agents handling
that problem and but I'm purposely
building the drill sets building the
workouts to show what I know that
they've been real evaluators want to
know I'm not you know if I was building
for the media I would know how to do
that I'm building it's just you know I
want you know what are the Dolphins want
to see what are the Raiders want to see
where the Colts want to see where the
Bengals want to see they want to see
dynamic movement they want to see the
combination of twitch and power they
want to see sustainability with it'll
work out because fatigue and recovery is
a big part of this you know today we're
gonna do about a 70 throw script so he's
gonna drop and throw 70 times today to
live receivers I'm gonna know a lot
tomorrow morning when I'm with them you
know where are you sore how's your arm
feel how your ribs feel I'm sure back
how's your head feeling how's your
ankles feel to this point he's been a
hundred percent in every after every
workout but increasing that workload on
him now
here's what I want to hand him we want
to hand him to a team ready to dominate
and OTA ready to go be an NFL dominant
football player so everything I'm doing
isn't for a performance standpoint I
don't care if he goes 70 of 72 today I
care that builds up a work capacity they
starts to better understand some
refinement Kanaks again we're talking
1/2 percent we're not talking 10 15
percent mechanical change so that when
he goes to an OTA and they asked him to
learn this big playbook executed
seven-on-seven script that is he is
making adjustments he can self evaluate
and he can self correct because that's
the biggest thing I've seen in the space
if you can't teach a player to self
correct in the midst of a practice the
NFL doesn't have a quarterback coach is
seeing they're filming every red point
Oh looking your front foot was too far
you didn't stay close long enough your
heads in the wrong position you gotta
you gotta you got it is xoxo xoxo so
teaching him so he can self correct if
anything starts going haywire or things
start getting a little sore here there
he knows what's causing that
um the best thing we can do is hand him
over to whatever NFL team traps if that
team go thank you thanks for letting us
do the rest thanks for letting us build
but we want to build but you gave us a
product that was healthy that was fresh
that mine was clear was excited about
learning excited about working excited
about me and a whole new tribe meaning
your organization excited about going
into the community and reaching out not
one that's broken down through the
pre-draft process laid down and burdened
and tired and exhausted and started we
want one that's fired up and Rado kicked
in a Phil spot all right well one last
question on him before I do want to get
to pick your brain about all the free
agent movement in the quarterback world
in the NFL is the floor is yours and
when you met to it when you realize that
he was a unicorn as a phrasing yeah well
my favorite story about him is it was
one of those you know Nike opening
regionals in May and Oakland California
and I had heard a lot about him I
watched all those tape and you can see
the talent but it was a very
undisciplined player at the time and we
do you know these regionals are not just
like underwear Olympics throw in cats we
put them through some pretty strenuous
stuff to kind of see what their capacity
to see what their work ethics like and
see if they're coachable and at the end
of the camp and this made the
documentary I actually called him out I
said - you're really talented
but everybody's enamored with your
talent all I see is the lack of
discipline and I said in a month from
now when you come back to the finals
because he got an invites the finals
based on his talent really and he's
incredibly talented I said he will not
thrive unless you fix this stuff well at
the time Kevin as his family was pre
offended right you could imagine being a
17 year old kid being told you're not as
great as everybody saying that you are
mm-hmm but instead of complaining about
it they did something about it and
there's video and this video lived
somewhere of him in a park in Hawaii
with his dad every afternoon going over
like these five to seven base old school
Bill Walsh Mike
and Mike McCarthy quarterback school
drills that I had adopted over time
because that had been in the last post I
just think they're really good
fundamental training drills he's in this
Park in Hawaii with orange cones set up
with his dad doing these for a month
straight so he comes to us in LA for the
finals where were Dondo Redondo Union
and the first drill he he does better
I've never seen video and then as the
day goes on I'm talking to my coaches
Jordan Palmer Quincy bring these guys
are like that's a totally different kid
and everybody knows I got he's totally
different I mean he went from being
undisciplined to perfectly just and he
knew more than anybody else in the whole
camp there was no doubt day one he was
the best player there and he proved it
as we went on the rest the summer and
the finals the opening finals and
everything but the point of the story is
that when to uh see something he's not
doing best he attacks it so he can go do
it best and yeah they had this great
smile and yeah he may be friends
everybody but deep down he's an assassin
and he does not he wakes up every
morning and he says how do I become the
best at the next thing and this was a 17
and you saw him doing this whole time in
Alabama and now you're seeing do it
you're getting ready for the NFL it's
amazing
alright let's get into some here and now
what what do you think Trent Dilfer of
Brady and Aryans hooking up how's that
gonna work how do you how successful do
you think that's going to be Tom Brady
and Tampa I'm a buyer I'm still down the
state like one of those Patriots fans
like I don't know then if it was gonna
look like with Tom not playing for the
Patriots oh I still haven't fully got
over that but to forecasted there in
Tampa finally they saw somebody's gonna
wear number 12 the right way in Tampa
that's a joke riche you can laugh I wear
12 I have not two and two together on
them I actually text them the 95 as I
now about times mom gets more and
properly don't don't embarrass the
number time what do you say
I this conversation about the system and
him not fitting okay it's not where
you're getting out because that has been
a lot of narrative around that right
Bruce Arians system is very diverse now
he's a hyper aggressive play caller
there's a different rating system and
play caller right I'm sure Kurt's
probably told beneful network audience
about this but the system Tom won't
learn any new place but there's no play
Tom doesn't know it's gonna be that
progression behind the teach so the
simplest way to look at has a lot of
what the Patriots did for a long time
was low to I so they read a lot of their
stuff low to high Bruce is a big high to
old guy every time he calls a play he's
trying to you know Knight the defense so
I think Tom's gonna like that that's
gonna be refresh it's nothing his arm
can't do it Tom's arm is still super
life I've even seen more chunk plays at
a Tom Brady more a more of a vertical
aspect to his passing eight I think his
skill set because his downfield accuracy
is leads obviously I think that's gonna
be showcased a little bit more my only
concern and I think a great guy to call
on this would be Carson Palmer I think
he can speak into this far better than I
could okay is a lot of these concepts
are extended drops they're gonna take a
little bit longer I instead of gain the
ball in two point one seven seconds
which i think is what Tom's average is
I'd have to check PFF he's gonna be more
like 2.75 and that doesn't sound like a
massive difference so but those big old
bodies that are moving really fast with
a lot of force that just gives them a
couple takes longer to get closer to her
I also like to see by week 12 how many
times he's been hitting this offense
relative to how many times he was hit in
the Patriots offense those are just
little things I'm going to look at but I
think they'll be wildly successful
because as that the skillset players
they have their Bruce is a genius
calling plays so I overall along with
Dilfer winded answer saying I like well
it's a great answer so Brady in Tampa
Phillip in Indy Bridgewater in Carolina
those are I guess the big moves
quarterbacks wise breezes obviously
staying put
which which new quarterback in a new
spot do you think is the best fit that
has the most upside for success that
I've just mentioned right there really I
don't know it's best I'm most curious
outside the Brady obviously everybody
the worlds were watching the Brady Tampa
dynamic in the same division the
Carolina Bridgewater Joe Brady you know
that this whole new mix what they're
doing offensively there I think that's
gonna be fascinating to watch I was very
impressed with Teddy when he played last
year I think he's a guy that if you
watch Joe burrow play LSU and how he
played for the most part on rhythm and
then when he had to create extra time
and space in a good job with that I
think that's who Teddy Bridgewater is
he's the guy that's gonna play on
schedule on time most the time it's
gonna dissect the defense pre-snap he's
gonna make very decisive reads post now
and then when he needs to extend to play
a little bit when he needs to create
some time and space he's a guy that can
do it
I've always been bullish on Teddy so I
think it's a good fit I'm excited to see
him get a chance to run the show and be
the dude so that that's probably the one
I'm most excited to watch outside the
Brady Tampa dynamic and what do you
think Cam's best fit is it's just
remarkable that he may have to get a
backup role and prove it or Jacksonville
be a spot on you know the Chargers are
probably knocking on the door for your
mentor II that you'll be working out
later on today I mean what do you what
do you think about can situation which
teams are making a move for him
potentially in the New England obviously
might need one I would call the New
England thing I really am agender said a
fan too so I think they've made up their
mind I think they're gonna go did it
would be a super guy yeah it wouldn't
surprise me if there's
more they bring in because bill loves
competition he's not a hand the keys of
the car to a young guy but I think it
really likes that open hand he did a
little that he played and then you hear
from what's going on in practice they
treat practice so seriously
most of what I heard from New England
was that he was really impressing
everybody not just coaches of players
with this leadership with his Jews with
his learning capacity with his
preparation I saw him a month or so ago
and I said you know if you look back and
look at the year how lucky were to be
the tongue is I can just watch Tom and
learn more than you make never taught
teach me so you're watching that and
really soak in it I think he understands
that the urgency every day of the
position but anyways that's the New
England no I think if I'm cam I'm
waiting to see how this draft unfolds
because I don't want to be a placeholder
for to uh or Herbert right or maybe love
Frank maybe love starts everybody falls
in love with love and you end up going
and you think you're the guy and you
think this is your chance and then all
of a sudden you see that oh no they just
drafted the guy and I'm just I'm the
sacrificial lamb to get to that guy I
know it sounds crazy talking about a Cam
Newton being a sacrificial lamb but if
you're a GM and you're looking to draft
one of those guys man I'd love to get
cam at a discount price and hedge my bat
but let's make no mistake about it
eighteen months it doesn't matter how
good can't place the guy draft it's
going to play hmm all right last one for
you Trent when Nick Foles was acquired
by the Bears and put in the same
quarterback room is Mitchell true Biscay
I've wondered what you think what this
means to all we're hearing is the
phrases is gonna push Mitch doesn't this
basically lift the kimono up about how
true Biscay isn't the number two overall
quarterback Savior that the Bears hoped
I give you the floor on what you thought
when you heard about the foals to bears
trade well what I like the trade I think
the Bears had to do something you can
you can say we love mitts risky and in
the same breath saying but he needs to
be pushed more he needs competition
he needs there needs to be an edge of
your room you know I mean he need every
day he needs to matter more so to speak
and EULA backup plan to Nick Foles who's
proven to be kind of that perfect guy
right the perfect guy that can come in
in a backup situation yeah
when football games especially if you're
as good as the Bears I think should be
kind of like his Eagles experience
really good team you don't have to do a
ton you're right that per manage the
game I see comes back to me which I
don't think is a you know as a knock you
do you are managing situations you're
not the reason the team's gonna win but
you're never gonna be the reason the
team loses I think Nick Foles was the
perfect guy for that and he's a great
guy you know I think that's the thing
that people miss in this quarter back
room dynamic is and I always go back to
my relationship met Matthew hustle back
is he's a great human being but he's as
good a human being as you're gonna me so
when you're going through hard times in
a room at least you're going through it
with somebody that he is a lifelong
friend I think Matthew and I had that
relationship that brought the best out
of both of us I think you have the same
dynamic that can happen in Chicago is
just nick foles presence in that
quarterback room is gonna help Mitch as
he goes through rocky tires even if that
means Nick is the woman playing at the
time and I know people can't wrap their
brain around that right oh no it's life
or death no it's it's really making sure
that room is as strong as it can be that
the stronger that room is the better
product on Sunday the quarterback flame
will be Trent you the man I've been
asking all my guests calling in for an
office or I don't know if that's some
sort of coach's room or whatever you're
in right now but now this is my coach's
office I'm only human being on the
institution's grounds okay it's by
figured so I've been asking what's
behind what's what's behind is there a
trophy what is that photograph you guys
this is all or Lipscomb Academy stuff
and then the Super Bowl trophy is back
there that Ray Lewis got for me I still
appreciate him getting it for me
oh man some other stuff Steve Largent
award
is something I'm really proud of the man
of the year for the Seattle Seahawks I
only have a few things up in my office
here Lipson Academy and those are them
but that's the that's the trophy ray got
for you oh my god that throw you made to
start things off in in Tampa by the way
that had to feel so damn good too
I'm simply God away I don't know if you
saw that Jameis tweeting out a farewell
to Tampa said he'll see him in February
did you see this all that I thought that
was pretty interesting God we didn't
talk about we would take a chance on
Jesus yes he's dangerous with the
football and I and I think that that
does get you beat Matt have any test
emeriti was too and then no Parcells was
over get that out of him when he went to
the Jets
I do think Jameis Winston with the right
coach could be a that's a steal right
there
didn't we say that about when Aryans
joined Ryan like I mean didn't you think
that the no risk it no biscuit I mean he
might have taken a little bit too much
of the risk it but he still threw him
5,000 yards worth of vet biscuits right
I mean so who's the right coach in the
right situation is the question right if
my homeroom was soaked up oh do not say
Mike Holmgren like he's the perfect
person to take it James because there's
freedom and how Mike lets you play but
there's also you better do it Mike I
mean you better learn it Mike's way and
the discipline of what I gained and what
Matthew gained at least from where we
came from to going you know Matthew
pharmacy longer my four years with Mike
was really learning the risk/reward of
the position and then be able to hear
stories of Steve Young Brett Favre Joe
Montana did it I mean three of the best
ever played the position and then he can
kind of create these parallels to where
you're at your career I could see my
eyes being a great if I could see Sean
Payton being a great influence on Jameis
Winston especially it's Rubina then I
get the pipe that tastes um he'll think
I don't know well that stands but
there's a certain guys that get
quarterbacks and they get their DNA and
they get how to kind of tweak it
there and get salat so the ceiling comes
out and the prayer doesn't talk Trent
you the man thanks for sharing tell - we
send our best you I got to meet him for
the first time at the bowl it's exactly
as you as you said the place like the
wattage on our Super Bowl said went up
when he walked on it there's no question
about it told a great story about how
you know he he ripped saving a little
bit after he threw that touchdown pass
against Georgia because Saban was still
pissed about the sack that he took so I
saw a little bit of that red ass - that
you're talking about he's gonna have a
little more today after I beat him in
her back Olympics - there will be if I
ever beat him in anything that's what I
won't tweet out or put on Instagram is
me eating - it's something okay three
years old if I can beat them it's on I
love it I can't wait to see it so how
can people follow you at dill furs dimes
right public on insta Trent Dilfer
okay very good will be found on you
think's the call Trent either man just
your family you bet